billionaires got scammed by a college
dropout yes you've probably heard the
story of theranos and
elizabeth holmes who is accused of
defrauding investors at their dose by
claiming that the technology was able to
run on a wide range of blood tests from
a finger prick test with just as much
accuracy as the traditional test
we in a second are going to go through a
couple of slides from one of their early
pitch decks in 2006.
that's right no one else is going to do
that but we're going to go back and
we're going to check the receipts in
2006 see what they were saying but first
a quick timeline overview in 2003 she
dropped out of stanford school of
engineering to start
theranos 2004 she raised a 6.9 million
dollars at about a 30 million valuation
very high valuation actually for 2004 so
that was pretty good job
2007 she raises another 43 million
dollars at around a 200 million
valuation then by 2010 just seven years
after she dropped out of college she has
their notes valued at one billion
dollars 2013 they unveiled its website
and launched a deal with walgreens to
commercialize theranose test so 10 years
after she dropped out at the age of 19
and nine years after she raised that
first round of funding they actually
unveiled their website 2014 they raised
400 million dollars at a
9 plus billion evaluation and then it
all starts to unravel from there
theranose test for herpes simplex virus
one was approved by the fda in july of
2015 and capital blue cross chose
therados as his preferred lab work
provider so still that is basically the
peak it's in july of 2015 they get this
fda approval for a specific test and
blue cross chooses them as a preferred
lab work provider
by october 2015 john kerry you who
published uh the book on their nose he
starts to publish articles criticizing
theranos and theranos has been forced to
suspend the use of its nanotainer for
all but one type of blood test so now by
the october 2015 we have a reporter who
starts to identify that there may be
some problems and starts to publish
these articles
november of 2015 just a month later
safeway deal falls apart after their
nose fails to meet key deadlines for
rollouts trouble in paradise july 2016
just two months after that walgreens
stops all testing at its theranose
wellness center in palo alto and then by
october 2016 basically one year after
john kerry you started to publish those
articles partner fund management who
invested 96 million dollars in
theranosis series c in 2014 sues the
company 2017 theranos settled with
centers for medicare and medicaid
services and partner fund management and
then in 2018 elizabeth holmes and uh the
gentleman balwani uh were indicted and
with their nose unable to find the buyer
was forced to close
so this basically was a journey from
2013 or 2003 to 2018 as a 15-year
journey from the time she dropped out
until ultimately they had to close the
business but in 2006 when they went out
to raise that 43 million round at around
200 million dollars
we have the deck we found the deck yep
that's right we got it so here is a
couple of the slides the first slide
that we have here is what they were
describing the business this is the
slide three in that 2006 2007 deck they
said that currently they had a couple of
deals they had a couple of phase fours
underway they had 120 to 300 million
dollar revenue in the next year and a
half and they had both companies
government agencies they were looking
for uh about 21 to 52 million dollars um
and when you look at this the two things
that immediately jump out to me is
something like the range of 120 to 300
million dollars in revenue
you're only 18 months out that's a
pretty big range to not know where
you're gonna fall in and i get that some
of these contracts are bigger but like
that's a pretty big range in hindsight
and then the second thing is uh it
appears like they are asking for 21 to
52 million dollars for validation i'm
assuming that's what they're trying to
raise those are really specific numbers
21 or 52 million and two is again that's
a really wide range it's literally more
than two times the bottom end of the
range that they were looking to
fundraise so again
if you saw this at the time you didn't
know anything was going on probably not
super big red flags but in hindsight
interesting next slide that we have here
is a slide that shows what the product
features are this slide is very beefy in
slide 8 it talks about the uses the
sample sizes the time the calibration
the dynamic range the accuracy
specifically calling out the accuracy
they were describing in 2006 2007 says
results comparable to gold standards
right maybe they should have said
bitcoin standard but bitcoin wasn't
around then uh and then they talk about
the data reporting it's immediate upload
from secured server and so what they
essentially were saying is they would be
able to prick your finger they'd be able
to do all these blood tests the accuracy
would be just as good as anything else
and that the data reporting would be
nearly immediate from their secured
servers so obviously as we know in
hindsight that actually wasn't possible
and they ended up not being able to do
this but that is what they were saying
in 201607 we then have another slide
which talks about the offering now this
is the slide that is pretty incredible
they're raising the offering is 30
million dollars so earlier we saw 21 to
52 million which was this range this
says that the offering is 30 million
dollars and give existing investors 15
to 20 million and new investors 10 to 15
million in these fundraising rounds this
is not odd for them to have hey here's
the number we think we're going to give
about this much to existing this much to
new investors so all that's fine but it
says it's a pre-ipo transaction
to facilitate rapid scaling of theranos
production and manufacturing
infrastructure and add to theranose
business development in salesforce
pre-ipo
is usually
used to describe we're going to go
public in the next 12 months right it's
right before the ipo
they were essentially using pre-ipo as a
description for an early stage company a
company that had not yet actually
shipped the product etc and they didn't
even have a website publicly available
that didn't come for another four or
five years and so when you think about
the language that's used in the deck
again this is all easy to play monday
morning quarterback in hindsight pre-ipo
transaction makes it sound much bigger
better right there's this element of
showmanship that goes into it uh again
hindsight red flag and i think we've got
one more slide uh that basically shows
uh their existing investors and when you
look at this there's two big things that
i think people call out right is uh on
one hand there's not a lot of silicon
valley investors on the other hand
there's a lot of really successful
people and so people continue to debate
is this a product of silicon valley is
this not a product of silicon valley i
don't think that you can so clearly
identify
whether
silicon valley culture created this or
didn't but it is interesting to see
according to that timeline 2003 when
holmes dropped out of stanford uh to
start to go build this she basically was
able to raise hundreds of millions of
dollars uh through the life cycle of the
business i think she raised over 500
million dollars right around 500 million
dollars for this business and ultimately
ended up closing in 2018.
very important for me to say
i think my brothers and i all agree the
beauty of america is that regardless of
what you are accused of you get to go
and have your day in court you get to in
front of a judge or in front of a jury
of your peers present your case we're
gonna see what happens i have no clue i
have no opinion frankly on what happened
i see what the allegations are we'll see
what the defense is and they'll figure
it out what i do think is very
interesting though is that this story
ended up
kind of moving into the mainstream
outside of the tech industry and now
people start to use it as an example as
to the downside to capitalism the
downside to the silicon valley and
venture capital funding system do we
think that's a fair critique of silicon
valley and capital to use this as a as
kind of a case
yeah i think to some degree right like
this was during a time where capital was
just
flowing everywhere right and we saw it
with wework when we were talking about
that a few weeks ago is like if you came
out and you said hey i'm going to change
the world i have a revolutionary product
that's going to change the way people
interact the way healthcare works and
all this other stuff and other companies
not just theranos and wework and others
but capital started flowing right and
venture capitalists were basically
throwing money at anything that had any
promise of working out and and they knew
that hey all i need is one out of 15 and
one out of 21 out of 50 of these to work
and really become a 100 billion dollar
company and i'm going to make my money
back and more so i think uh venture
capital is to blame for some reason of
kind of not doing their due diligence on
the business and realizing what was
going on obviously if there's illegal
things going on and people are being
shady and hiding things or whatever uh
eventually gets found out or not i think
that that is obviously not necessarily
venture capital's fault but speaking of
the structure of the system and the way
capital is typically deployed i think
that uh yeah it's fair to probably say
that venture capital and the firms that
are associated with theranos deserve
some kind of pushback so why do we bring
this up today her trial starts today
right so i agree with the fact that she
should have a fair trial and go before a
jury of her peers and all that but i
think besides what you like kind of
think i think she was really good at
selling optimism to an investor right
and that's what a lot of these venture
capitals are looking for they're looking
for a great opportunity um and look she
was selling the the retail side of
things the safeway and walgreens and how
people can come in um similar like
almost like a fast mode where you can
get tested without having to actually
have the device in your home and then
the military applications and all that
um i used as an example to kind of see
like
people start companies and they raise
all this money on basically an idea
right so she raised millions and
millions of dollars before she had a
website available to people right
websites don't matter
they may not matter but i'm joking if
you're looking for 21 million dollars
for validity almost right for validation
then maybe put
i don't know 20k and build a website
should that be uh should that be a
requirement moving forward as you can't
raise 20 million dollars you have a
website or a product or revenue yeah
that could be a requirement for me it's
a hardware business yeah right so it's
obviously capital intensive i i think
the crazier part about this is uh and
this again highly debated but i do think
that if you go back and you look at many
of the
best
companies that made it not all of them
but some of them
there was a fake it till you make it
component right the whole element of if
a customer asks you hey can you do this
yes and they go back and they figure it
out right again i don't think many
people think that that's a problem they
actually look at that as like a good
business skill
the difference i think is one it's
healthcare related right so obviously
people are much more sensitive when
you're dealing with testing of
somebody's blood and are you accurate or
you're not accurate does it have
negative side effects in terms of the
care they get all that type of stuff and
then two is when you start getting into
the regulated world of the fda and a lot
of these health care
you know components
it's not the same thing like a customer
asked it can you do something and you
run back and you create it because my
understanding again i could be wrong but
but my understanding of the device is
that it never actually did what it said
it did yeah right and so they just never
got there
did they run out of time i don't know
right but i do think that that's the key
piece is uh there's a very fine line um
and you know look uh in some crazy way
there's some software companies that you
could say they faked it till they made
it and they did make it so they before
they ran out of money before there was
issues they made it and they got the
product whatever so they're companies
that you know they don't make it and
this is a a perfect gig but i think
what's up guys bang bang it's your boy
pomp thanks so much for watching the
best business show our goal is to make
this the largest most actionable
business show in the world and to do
that we need your help we've partnered
with sofi as our exclusive sponsor
because they have a piece of software
that we think will help you take the
information that we share on a daily
basis and make it actionable we want
every single person to pursue and
achieve financial security and financial
freedom in order to do that you gotta
act and sofi allows you to do it so you
can go to
sofi.com today you can open up an
account and when you open up an account
you can invest in all sorts of different
types of assets etfs individual stocks
ipos bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even
have an automated investing function if
you want to invest sofi can help you
they've got a couple of different offers
that you can benefit from the first open
an invest account and they'll give you
up to a thousand bucks for free kind of
a no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right sofi doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer it from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more the best business show
together we're gonna build the biggest
show in the world
[Music]